no hay un día sin que evo morales-
irrumpa en la campaña de bolivia desde
argentina el exgobernante también es el
jefe de campaña del movimiento al
socialismo y sus adversarios afirman que
tendrá el verdadero poder si luisa se
gana los comicios del país solamente
luchó será presidente de bolivia con
todas las atribuciones y
responsabilidades que eso implica confío
totalmente pero la sombra de morales es
muy fuerte y muchas cosas que dice
causan revuelo en bolivia el candidato
del movimiento al socialismo tuvo que
decir que no comparte con evo morales
que la prensa sea el enemigo número uno
pero es un pensamiento del compañero
nadie puede nadie puede decirle lo que
piensa él siempre ha tuiteado lo que él
piensa pero nosotros tenemos un criterio
diferente aunque las diferencias entre
los dos parecen mínimas cuando se
refieren al rol de los periodistas no
los periodistas tiene que ponerse la
camiseta de la paz y recuperamos la pata
de los bolivianos
sus adversarios no creen que evo morales
mantenga distancia del poder si arce
triunfa
el candidato centrista que viene segundo
en las encuestas dice que votar por luís
arce será igual que votar por evo
morales
bien
[Música]
m
[Aplausos]
para el partido de derecha creemos
tercero en las encuestas arte fue
elegido por morales como candidato para
protegerlo de las denuncias de
corrupción en su contra es la persona
que ha puesto a dedo morales ayma para
que puedan protegerle todos los actos de
corrupción tras casi 14 años en el poder
el domingo los bolivianos dirán si evo
morales- continuará o no marcando el
futuro de la política del país